hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen hier zu einer neuen
wertvorstellung ich sehe ein bisschen
fertig auswahl gestern donnerstag und
das sei nicht ganz normaler tag aber wir
waren feiern und es war karneval und es
ist immer noch karneval aber ich habe
mir gedacht hey breckwoldt ihren video
und wahrscheinlich da ich gerade
produziert es gab sogar montag und das
auch wieder karneval räume man kann da
nicht von entfliehen aber ich wollte
euch jene kleine mops sein und zwar es
sieht alles ganz normal aus aber ich hab
so einen scheiß rucksack auf und
verschwand
das ist nämlich die backpack mod das ist
die adventure backpack mod ich möchte
euch da gar nicht so viel von zeigen
weil das eine mod ist wie ich finde die
jeder einfach haben sollte minecraft
weil ich dachte auch erste jahr das ist
vielleicht im ort die fügt zu 12
rucksack hinzufügt hier das alles hinzu
das sind extrem viele sachen der
beispielsweise sachen wie die menus
bottle was man dann quasi trinken kann
das ist nämlich das kommt beispielsweise
aus denen aus dem melonen rucksack hier
aus dem melonen rucksack bei der melonen
rucksack obwohl ich den aussehen ihr
kapital der melonen drucks hat
beispielsweise der fühlt sich nach einer
zeit immer mit immer mit melonen fühlt
sich nach einer gewissen zeit immer mit
melanie use also einfach mit melonensaft
e mail ohne ist eigentlich voll das
komische wort wenn man sich das mal
sogar legen nicht gerade einfach nur
noch irgendwie betrunken oder oder
melone melonen e-mail ohne riecht
komisch
jedenfalls macht dieser mellon adventure
backpack 40 halt immer mit melonen
sachen und so damit man immer so melonen
dabei hat dann gibt es aber unter
anderem auch noch einen kaktus backpack
das cactus backpack fühlt sich nach der
zeit einfach mit wasser also das wird
quasi immer das sind 33 rucksäcke die
einfach nur so verschiedene
flüssigkeiten immer sich einfühlen und
dann gibt es hier noch das comeback das
fühlt sich nach der zeit einfach mit
milch wenn man denn immer so ein
bisschen links dabei hat also wenn man
immer so ein bisschen immer ein bisschen
noida bei twitter braucht man dafür sich
dass wir hier unten auf fällt damit mit
milch und so weiter und so fort
das nämlich drei big packs die haben
quasi besondere
sachen quasi einfach wenn ich mir jetzt
auch beispielsweise hier mal ein was
könnte ich mir da man nehmen was könnten
wir dann mal wieder mal die deluxe box
wenn ich hier beispielsweise aachen
hatte das geht nicht mit der deluxe box
dafür benötige ich nämlich eine ganz
bestimmte okay ich finde dass jetzt
gerade nicht aber es gibt auch einen
backpack auf jeden fall was man dann
quasi einfach auf hat und dann kann man
hier quasi nicht drauf drücken sondern
dann kriegt man quasi sonst liebling
beck das ist dann einfach sonne sondern
so ein sorbet was man da drauf klicken
kann und dann wird man quasi man setzt
an den rucksack einfach hin macht dann
da rechtsweg darauf warte ich glaube ich
kann euch das mal so zeige ich glaube
man muss einfach ja man muss ihn
hinstellen dann drücke ich hier drauf
dann habe ich ihr song better dabei kann
ich dann quasi halt nur nachtschlaf aber
ich kann auf jeden fall damit schlafen
also wirklich quasi so richtig abenteuer
mäßig an habe ich beispielsweise noch
das grid backpack wenn ich mir dass
beispielsweise einfach mal auf setzt
also wenn ihr einfach so mache
zack und dann gehe ich mal ganz kurz in
den game mode 0 und gehe dann hier unter
wasser
dann seht ihr schon damit kann ich
länger unter wasser atmen bzw ach ich
muss den aussetzen mussten aussetzen
oder ich muss denn ich habe ihn sogar
auf die sowieso geht das jetzt gar nicht
gut backpacker youtube brief underwater
okay ich habe keine ahnung wieso das mit
dem skript ding hier gerade nicht
funktioniert weil eigentlich
funktioniert das gerät auch schon jeder
kann man dann halt so einmal rein dann
fühlt sich das halt mit flüssigkeit was
ihr euch gezeigt habe das verstehe ich
gar nicht mehr eigentlich kann man mit
dem skript backpack unter wasser atmen
und dann gibt es halt auch noch andere
die noch zwei andere die einen anderen
möglichkeiten haben und zwar das chicken
backpack dass hier das drop nach der
zeit immer wenn man das auf hat drop das
immer so ein paar eier
also das ist beispielsweise wenn man so
unterwegs das unterhemd hat nach und
nach ein paar eier also damit kann man
dann quasi einfach kaffee und kuchen
backen oder irgendwas machen gibt es
hier noch das bett backpack damit ist es
quasi einfach möglich wenn ich das auf
habe dass es dann quasi dass ich im
dunkeln sehen kann das ist besonders gut
geeignet wenn ich in irgendeiner aria
bin quasi die einfach schlecht
beleuchtet ist et cetera pp und dann
kann ich auf jeden fall mit das bett peg
peg peg aussetzen dann gibt es hier noch
einige andere
sachen die hinzugefügt werden wie
beispielsweise boote mit denen ich rum
fahren kann und so weiter und so fort
das gibt es gibt einfach so mega neiße
sachen die hier auf jeden fall zugefügt
werden kann ich mich dann auch mal
reinsetzen und so dass es beispielsweise
shape motorbooten das hat sogar das
sieht so richtig cool aus eigentlich und
das ist auch ein bisschen so dass es
nicht halt direkt kaputt geht wenn ich
irgendwo gegen fahrer seht ihr schon
also es werden auf jeden fall coole
sachen hinzugefügt den rest kann man auf
jeden fall sich mal obst es ruckelt
donnerstag ich würde euch auf jeden fall
nur empfehlen euch herunterzuladen weil
es richtig cooles weil damit quasi diese
ganzen becks hinzugefügt werden wenn man
noch viele andere sachen halt
beispielsweise wie einfach es ist halt
einfach wirklich keine normale backpack
mord wie ich das gedacht hatte
sondern es geht wirklich mehr sachen
hinzu ich kann beispielsweise ein
lagerfeuer hinsetzen und das sieht
richtig gut aus eigentlich echt recht
cool ich freue mich dass ich euch diese
modifikation zeigen konnte ich würde
mich freuen wenn ihr euch herunterlade
ich würde mich freuen wenn das video
bewertet und ich würde mich freuen wenn
ihr das nächste mal wieder einschaltet
und dann würde ich sagen war stand das
video und der den unterschied
das ist nicht wahr hier ist wieder
einfing geschafft freuen ihr könnt euch
bestimmt an die facts folge hat das ist
ne 0 164 prozentige chance dass ein
schafft pink ist und ich hab das pinkeln
er ist das geil
das ist ja richtig cool das freut mich
gerade richtig hatte das eigentlich
gerade ihren mund aufgemacht beim beim
reden
hallo hallo hallo freunde wie das war's
mit dem video sieht man das natürlich